the bitcoin illiquid supply is
absolutely popping will clemente the
young wizard tweeted this morning and
said another uptick in illiquid supply
shock now breaking slightly above 2021
highs currently at the highest level
that has been since late 2017. think
this local bitcoin price consolidation
is nearing an end soon now what this
specifically is talking about is that
illiquid supply when you get a super
super illiquid asset and new demand
comes supply demand economics take over
there's just not enough circulating
supply or liquid supply for everyone to
buy so when you get increase in demand
illiquid supply
price has to go up to accommodate
everyone now the big questions are we
know for a fact that there is an
illiquid supply we can see it on the
data we know exactly we can prove it to
you you're looking at it right here what
we don't know is will there be a
material increase in demand moving
forward that is the big question but if
we get an increase in demand and you
have an illiquid supply the price goes
up now what we do think is very
interesting about bitcoin specifically
is if i was to ask you almost any other
asset in the world tell me how many
total units of that asset exist tell me
how many are in circulation and tell me
what are the decisions in the future
about the supply you could tell me
pretty closely but you couldn't tell me
with certainty so when you think of
supply and demand the supply side of an
equation is known generally but not
known with specificity or with certainty
in the future i'll give you two examples
if i ask you about a company how many
shares are outstanding you can tell me
that and that is the circulating
supplier the market cap of that stock
what you cannot tell me is what is the
total number of shares this company will
ever have why well one they can actually
do stock buybacks so they can actually
contract the outstanding supply and the
second thing they can do is they can
always issue more shares so they can
expand the supply and so again we know
today if it's a publicly traded company
how many stocks are outstanding how many
shares are outstanding but you can't
tell me moving forward what the
decisions are going to be and so what
ultimately people do is they try to go
ahead and look at the supply and they
try to model what do we think the supply
is going to look like over the next
let's say 10 years and then what do we
think the demand for this stock will be
over that 10-year period as well and
through those two assumptions on supply
and demand you get what people think the
price will be moving forward okay that's
how stocks work if i then go to another
commodity let's say something like gold
and i say to you how much gold exists in
circulation you have a pretty good guess
you can't prove it to me like you could
with a public stock but you have a
pretty good guess then if i said to you
well how much gold is going to be dug
out of the ground moving forward and
that enters that circulating supply
you could tell me with some level of
accuracy because what you do is you look
over the last 50 years and say okay how
much gold was dug out each year let's
just extrapolate that out over the next
10 years and that'll give you again some
level of accuracy but you don't know
with certainty and you can't prove that
that is actually what is going to happen
so what you're left with on a commodity
basis is we think that this is what the
current supply is we think this is what
the supply chain is going to be over the
next 10 years and we think this is going
to be the demand and now people have
become pretty good at this and so they
can start to model out what the price
will be in the future
with bitcoin it's different
when you take a supply demand equation
for bitcoin
one side of it the supply side is known
with certainty i know exactly what the
total supply of bitcoin is 21 million i
can show you down to the individual
bitcoin exactly how many are in
circulation right now and i also can
show you and prove and verify and have
your eyes see that only 900 bitcoin a
day are coming into the circulating
supply right now and that will continue
until the next having which is
pre-programmed and then we will go from
900 bitcoin a day to 450 and then we'll
go for a certain number of blocks and
then we'll have again and so this will
continue until all of the bitcoin have
been mined and so the difference with
bitcoin is that the supply side of the
supply demand equation is known with
certainty we know what the total supply
is we know what the circulating supply
is and we know with certainty because
it's a programmatic monetary policy what
the future monetary policy decisions
will be and so therefore people are only
left to model the demand side of the
equation if you know supply with
certainty you can focus on modeling
demand and so things like what will
showed us are incredibly accurate in
terms of predicting what is likely to
happen in the future because we do not
have to try to model supply and demand
we simply have to model demand in this
specific asset that's why things like
the stock to flow model and others are
so deadly accurate